let's go let's say I have some type of a
block here and let's say this block has
a mass of M so the mass of this block is
equal to M and it's sitting on this you
could view this as an inclined plane or
a ramp or some type of wedge and we want
to think about what might happen to this
block and we'll start thinking about the
different forces that might keep it in
place or not keep it in place in all of
the rest so the one thing we do know is
this if if this whole set up is near the
surface of the earth and we will assume
that it is for this for the sake of this
video that there will be the force of
gravity trying to bring trying to bring
or attract this mass towards the center
of the earth and vice versa at the
center of the earth towards this mass so
we're going to have some force of
gravity let me start right at the center
of this mass right over here and so
you're going to have the force of
gravity the force due to gravity is
going to be equal to the gravitational
field near the surface of the earth and
so we'll call that G we'll call that G
times the mass let me just write it the
mass times the gravitational field near
the surface of the earth and it's going
to be downwards we know that or at least
towards the surface of the earth now
what else is going to be happening here
well it gets a little bit confusing
because you can't really say that you
know it that you can do can't say the
normal force is acting directly against
this force right over here because
remember the normal force acts
perpendicular to a surface so over here
the surface is not perpendicular to the
force of gravity so we have to think
about it a little bit differently than
we do when we if this was sitting on
level ground well the one thing that we
can do and frankly that we should do is
maybe we can break up this force the
force due to gravity we can break it up
into components that are either
perpendicular to the surface or that are
parallel to the surface and then we can
use those to figure out what's likely to
happen and what are the potentially
netting forces or balancing forces over
here so let's see if we can do that
let's see if we can break this
force vector the force due to gravity
into a component that is perpendicular
that is perpendicular to the surface of
this ramp and also another component
that is parallel to the surface of this
ramp let me do that in a different color
that is parallel to the surface of this
ramp and I'll use a little so this is a
little bit unconventional notation but
I'll call this one over here I'll call
this the force due to gravity that is
perpendicular to the RAM that little
upside-down T I'm saying that's
perpendicular because it shows a line
that's perpendicular to I guess this
bottom line this horizontal line over
there and this blue thing over here I'm
going to call this the force the or the
part of force due to gravity that is
parallel that is parallel I'm just doing
those two upward vertical bars to social
something that is parallel is parallel
to the surface so this is the component
of force due to gravity this
perpendicular component of force that is
parallel so let's see if we can use a
little bit of geometry and trigonometry
given that this this this wedge is that
a is that a theta degree third theta
degree incline relative to the
horizontal if you were to measure this
angle right over here you would get
theta so in future videos we'll make it
more concrete like 30 degrees or 45
degrees or whatever but let's just keep
it general if this is Theta let's figure
out what these components of this of the
gravitational force are going to be well
we can break out our geometry over here
this I'm assuming is a right angle and
so if this is a right angle we know that
the sum of a of the angles in a triangle
add up to 180 so this angle if this
angle this angle and this 90 degrees
right angle says 90 degrees add up to
180 then that means that this one and
this one need to add up to 90 degrees or
if this is Theta this angle right over
here this angle right over here is going
to be 90 minus theta now the other thing
that you may or may not remember from
geometry classes if I have two parallel
lines if I have two parallel lines here
if I have two parallel
and then I have a transfer so I'm going
to assume this line is parallel to this
line and then I have a transversal so
let's say I have a line that goes like
this we know from basic geometry that
this angle is going to be equal to this
angle it comes from alternate interior
angles and we go and we prove it in the
geometry module or in the geometry
videos but hopefully this makes a little
bit of intuitive sense and you could
even think about how these angles would
change is the transversal changes in all
of the rest but the parallel lines makes
this angle similar to that angle or
actually makes it identical makes it
congruent this angle is going to be the
same measure as that angle so can we
apply that anywhere over here well we
have and all that's not obvious this
line is perpendicular to the surface of
the earth right over here that I'm kind
of shading in blue and so is so is this
force vector it is also perpendicular to
the surface of the earth so this line
over here and this line over here in
magenta are going to be parallel I can
even draw that that line and that line
are both parallel when you look at it
that way you'll see that this big line
over here can be viewed as a transversal
or you could have these this angle and
this angle are going to be congruent
they're going to be alternate interior
angles so this angle and this angle by
the exact same idea here it just looks a
little bit more confusing here because I
have all sorts of things but this line
and this line are parallel you can view
this right over here as a transversal so
this and this are congruent angles so
this is 90 minus theta degrees this two
will be 90 minus theta degrees 90 minus
theta degrees now given that can we
figure out this angle well one thing
we're assuming that this yellow force
vector right here we're assuming that it
is perpendicular to the surface of this
plane or perpendicular to the surface of
this ramp so that's perpendicular this
right here is 90 minus theta so what is
this angle up here going to be equal to
this angle let me do it in green what is
this angle up here going to be equal to
so this angle plus 90 minus theta
90 must be equal to 180 or this angle
plus 90 minus theta must be equal to let
me write this down I don't want to do
too much in your head so let's call it X
so X plus 90 minus theta plus Plus this
90 degrees right over here Plus this 90
degrees needs to be equal to 180 degrees
we can let's see we can subtract 180
degrees from both sides so you subtract
90 twice you get your subtract 180
degrees you get X minus theta is equal
to 0 or X is equal to theta so whatever
the inclination of the plane is or of
this ramp that is also going to be this
angle right over here and the value to
that is is that now we can use our basic
trigonometry to figure out this
component and this component of the
force of gravity and to see that little
bit clearer let me shift this force
vector down over here the parallel
component let me shift it over here and
you can see the perpendicular component
plus the parallel component is equal to
the total force due to gravity and you
should also see that this is a right
triangle that I have set up over here
this is parallel to the plane this is
perpendicular to the plane and so we can
use basic trigonometry to figure out the
magnitudes of the perpendicular force
due to gravity and the parallel force
due to gravity so the magnitude let's
think about a little bit the magnitude
of the I'll do it over here the
magnitude of the perpendicular force due
to gravity or the compare I say the
component of gravity that is
perpendicular to the ramp the magnitude
of that vector a lot of fancy notation
but it's really just the length of this
of this vector right over here so the
magnitude of this over the hypotenuse
over the hypotenuse of this right
triangle well what is the hypotenuse of
this right triangle well it's going to
be the magnitude of the total of the
total of the total of the total a
gravitational force I guess you could
say that and so you could say that is
that is M that is mg we could write it
we could write it like this but that's
really the well I could write it like
that and so this is going to be equal to
what we have the
if we're looking at this angle right
here we have the adjacent over the
hypotenuse remember so let me just in a
new color
induce in a new color so a Toa cosine is
adjacent over hypotenuse so this is
equal to cosine of the angle so cosine
of theta is equal to adjacent over the
hypotenuse so if you multiply both sides
by the magnitude of the hypotenuse you
get the component of our vector that is
perpendicular to the surface of the
plane is equal to the magnitude of our
four of our of our gravity or the force
due to gravity the magnitude of the
force due to gravity times the cosine of
theta times the cosine of theta we'll
apply this in the next video
just so you can make the numbers a
little more concrete sometimes just the
notation makes it confusing you'll see
it's really actually pretty
straightforward and then this second
thing we could use the same logic we
have if we think about the parallel
vector right over here the magnitude the
magnitude of the force of the component
of the force due to gravity that is
parallel to the plane over the magnitude
of the force due to gravity which is the
magnitude of mg that is going to be
equal to what well we have this is the
opposite side to the angle and then so
the blue stuff is the opposite side or
at least its length is the opposite side
of the angle and then right over here
this magnitude of M G that is the
hypotenuse so you have the opposite over
the hypotenuse opposite over hypotenuse
sine of an angle is opposite over
hypotenuse so this is going to be equal
to the sine of theta this is equal to
the sine of theta or you multiply both
sides times the magnitude of the of the
force due to gravity and you get the
component of the force due to gravity
that is parallel that is parallel to to
the ramp is going to be it is going to
be the is going to be the force due to
gravity total times cosine sorry times
sine of theta
times sine of theta so if you have these
and hopefully you should see where this
came from because you could all if you
ever have to derive this again when
you're you know thirty years after you
took calculus or physics class you
should be able to do it but if you know
if you know this right here if you know
this right here and this right here we
can all of a sudden start breaking down
the forces into things that are useful
to us because we could say hey look this
isn't moving down into this plane so
maybe there's some normal force that's
completely netting it out in this
example and maybe if there's nothing to
keep it up if there's no friction maybe
this thing will start accelerating due
to the parallel force and we'll think a
lot more about that and if you ever
forget these think about them
intuitively you don't have to go through
this whole parallel line and transversal
and all of that if this is if this if
this angle went down to zero if this
angle went down to zero then we'll be
talking about essentially a flat surface
there is no inclination there and this
angle goes down to zero then all of the
four should be acting perpendicular to
the surface of the plane so if this
going to 0 if the perpendicular force
should be the same thing as the graph of
the total gravitational force and that's
why it's cosine of theta because cosine
of zero right now is 1 and so these
would equal each other and if this
equaled zero then the parallel component
of gravity should go to zero because
gravity will only be acting downwards
and once again if sine of theta is zero
so the force of gravity this parallel
will go to zero so if you ever forget
just do that little intuitive thought
process and you'll remember which one is
sine in which one is cosine